rando pays vous propose cette semaine un
numéro spécial pour découvrir le
chantier de réaménagement du sentier
entre le cap anglais et des louches
à l'heure où le soleil se lève au dessus
du gîte de bélouve les ouvriers de l'eau
élèves sont déjà prêts à embaucher comme
tous les matins depuis plusieurs
semaines cette équipe à temps
l'hélicoptère qui les conduira à quatre
kilomètres plus loin sur leur lieu de
travail
une nouveauté jusqu'à présent dehors de
chantiers très spécifique seuls les
matériaux étaient transportés par la
voie des airs
mais avec ce chantier à deux heures de
marche le gain en temps de travail
s'avère finalement plus économique
ce matin-là il est prévu une visite de
chantier en compagnie de bernard
labrosse référent santé de l'eau est
nette et de nicolas payet représentant
le département
en quatre minutes de vol nous voici à
2000 mètres d'altitude sur le gr20 un
peu en dessous du cap anglais c'est ici
la jonction entre les deux tronçons de
chantier la première tranche a en effet
déjà été livrés en 2013
la seconde est en cours de travaux nous
laissant les ouvriers se rendre vers
l'actuel chantier pour commencer notre
visite par le premier tronçon achevée
pour cela nous remontons à l'envers en
direction du cap anglais
cette première partie de sentiers de
deux kilomètres jusqu'au cap anglais a
été aménagé entre avril et juillet 2013
ce qui a permis entre autres d'y faire
passer les trailer de bourbon lors de la
dernière édition du grand raid sur ce
sentier en effet les aménagements saute
aux yeux des marges bien taillée il y en
a plus de 800 des échelles 9 grâce à eux
nous atteignons rapidement la fin du
tronçon au cap anglais
si aujourd'hui la progression est aisé
il en a pas toujours été de même dans
sept régions très arrosées
on est sur un sentier qui traverse toute
la forêt de bélouve une forêt de bélouve
qui est une vraie éponge qui reçoit des
quantités d'eau phénoménale à longueur
d'année et qui était devenu dangereux
nous avons entrepris de remettre en état
ce sentier avec une première
problématique à gérer ces lots qu'est ce
qu'on fait de l'eau l'eau fait un
travail d'érosion et petit à petit eh
bien on le sentait va se creuser les
marches servent à améliorer la
progression du marcheur mais aussi
retiennent le sol entre les séries de
marche ont créé des évacuations d'eau
que l'on appelle les dalots c'est le
terme réunionnais qui désigne un
caniveau un caniveau que l'on créé sur
le sentier pour évacuer l'eau en dehors
de l'emprise du sang en aux flammes
coc
c'est dalo sont donc indispensables pour
que le sentier ne se transforme plus
entourant saison des pluies lors du
retour on peut constater à quel point
ils sont nombreux sur ce tronçon
près de 150 ils ont en effet été creusés
à chaque fois que le relief le
permettait mais voilà là on arrive sur
l'emplacement d'un dalot qui a été
construit pas par hasard
là le säntis qui continue se retrouvent
encaissé les deux talus monte à droite
et à gauche ne donne aucune possibilité
d'évacuer l'eau alors je profite d'un
talus qui est là qui rabaissait pour
installer un dalot est derrière ce
passage encaissé dès que le talus me
permettra d'offrir à une autre
possibilité d'évacuation d'eau j'en
profiterais et ce dans l'eau est bien
large c'est d'abord parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres qui va couler et puis
ensuite pour une ligne dure qui dure
dans le temps qui ne se rebouche pas
facilement on a vraiment forcer sur la
construction de ces dalo
un autre type d'aménagement ce sont les
platelages de véritables passerelles
pour franchir les zones humides toujours
boueuse mais qui permettent aussi de
canaliser les randonneurs pour éviter
qu'ils ne créent leur propre passage
dans la végétation environnante
nous voici désormais sur la seconde
tranche de travaux débutés en juin ici
les marchés les dalots taille et
récemment permet de mesurer l'ampleur de
la tâche
surtout lorsque photos à l'appui on peut
comparer l'état du sentier avant
aménagement et si la façon si n'a été si
franche dont les dalots sont taillés
nous interpelle c'est en retrouvant les
ouvriers au travail que l'on comprend
comment il arrive à ce résultat le
secret ce sont ses tronçonneuses équipés
de chaînes spéciales en carbure cette
chaîne c'est aussi pour couper les
racines le rôle à la boue du bois et des
âmes pedro fait pas trop de rhodia il
faut pas du tout fait un bond l'avant ce
qui s'était passé à la loupe des soucis
avec les racines ou salaires
hamamouche
sur un sentier c'est l'ouvrier qui doit
s'adapter en permanence aux terrains
chaque marché différentes presque de
l'artisanat de man se ça ressemble quand
c'est fini c'est c'est pas le même mange
quoi c'est des fois il faut mettre un
matin des x 80 cm c'est notre vision
c'est il n'y a pas de critère c'est nous
qui décidons
quant aux matériaux utilisés il s'agit
d'un bois traité importés et
hélitreuillé sur place un gage de
résistance et de longévité
c'est d'abord comme ça elle va durer
peut-être une quinzaine d'années tandis
avons travaillé avec du credo du quota
mais rien le côté maya battu à faire
quoi avec cinq sélections en plus de
solidité en du côté du chantier serait
ça ça va résister mieux lorsqu après
avoir quitté les ouvriers on se retrouve
sur la zone qui n'a pas encore été
aménagés la différence est flagrante
ça glisse ça colle la progression est
plus lente
après le passage de la ravine les
échelles matérialise la fin du deuxième
tronçon dont les travaux s'achèveront
très prochainement
c'est aussi la fin de notre visite est
l'occasion de conclure sur ce chantier
on est sur un sentier qui est très
important en matière de développement
touristique matière de développement
économique pour les hauts de l'île on
est sur un sentier qui va faire la
jonction entre deux sites majeurs pour
l'accueil du public en milieu naturel
le gîte de bélouve d'un côté de piton
des neiges de l'autre côté de gîtes qui
vont faire l'objet d'une reconstruction
dans les années à venir
on procède à des travaux relativement
lourd 1 on reconstruit la plateforme du
sentier l'objectif c'est d'intervenir de
façon plus conséquente en matière
d'investissements au départ pour avoir
un sentier avec une durée de vie
beaucoup plus importante et revenir
beaucoup moins en entretien on espère
que en améliorant les conditions de
cheminement on attire davantage de
personnes et donc la fréquentation de la
zone augmente
au terme de cette deuxième tranche de
travaux on aura un sentier beaucoup plus
confortable en faire le cheminement est
peut-être que certains randonneurs garde
un mauvais souvenir certes un trailer un
très mauvais souvenir de ce passage
n'hésitez pas à revenir sur cet
itinéraire convient de faire pour vous